meno male che non larga è un gioco meno
male guarda che la a tutti ragazzi è
pervenuto questo noleggio sono
famigerati siamo su stickman fight che
un gioco che funziona bene lasciatevi
piaggio e qualche tabella qui per
giocare online
vai su quick match e la scatola dopo un
po si eleva a portandoti in una partita
l'obiettivo sarà quello di menare gli
altri tipo ii michael jackson
[Musica]
no ti stavo toccando io ho mezzo diverso
però sarà il pezzo di è una figata
incredibile se non fosse che sto
pezzente io lo stesso stavo aspettando
già la prima posso fare come si fa ci
sono le armi
aiuto aiuto come faccio prendere le armi
le voglio anch'io alla prova fare una
mostra c'è una katana li hai a porta non
vale non ho mai giocato a sta roba che
gigi tua sorella gigi come si fa a parte
una persona in base a quante schiaffi
dai via bene per il deretano nicchia un
mitra ak eva felices aiuto piazza come
questo gioco dai l'avevo facciano un po
vincenzo ebete no no no no oddio aiuto
quanto ci stiamo mirando sembra un
incontro di dragon ball
sì perché il ragazzo non è problema le
armi cantano vicino a lui però si vabbé
raga sempre vicino a lui e al bastardo
da ischia a maledetto chiede allarmi
adesso vieni a prendere il cecchino ieri
ha preso del cecchino un gol
sì però ma non muore a ecco la milian
ora che gli sparava mio e mi va bene
possibile chi cazzo è questo
raga arrivato un altro dice ai apcom e
stato mi ha battuto anche con lui ma
cosa ci siamo di nuovo io dove sono sono
verde perfetto capiamoci un attimo
maritè tutti buongiorno sui 1 su ok ci è
rimasto solo lui non ci credo non
l'aveva picchiata sta diventato un
fenomeno da momento all'altro non ho
capito i comandi ma credo che ci sia gli
altri stanno fermi tanto ci mettiamo noi
e siamo morti noi due come degli
efficienti quanto ci ho messo per per
avere la supremazia quanto sono morto
schiacciato cus ostra mica ecco la roma
cosa diavolo è successo a me quindi
posso andare a picchiarla jabar camarca
gialli infame no kat
c'era il bazooka porca vacca eccolo
no quello lo sniper poi abbiamo tolto
non glielo cocco scherzava e per cannes
anticamente possiamo chiarire in
amicizia ecco quest'anno si chiami ci
sia questa si chiama guerra aia ha poi
non essere così violento per fare stati
affatto
e a madonna ragazzi aiuto aiuto c'è una
pistola l'ha presa
se che culo madonna come vinto sto
livello abbiamo cambiati anche un piatto
non ho capito il perché stavolta ci sono
arrivato prima io ammazzatevi voi due
ditte che sono morti
adesso si può dire gli a k 18 madonna
sia bordello noti come ha fatto a
vincere può aggiungersi il verde vi
prego che se facciamo tutti nei
navigatori e così almeno siamo siamo in
quanto siamo 24 ancora più in bordello
togliti quello è un serpente o è verde
non un serpente
vi prego qualcuno mi spieghi sano adesso
arrivato pure un verde perché ci sono i
serpenti aiuto vai giù ma potevi
startene a casa tua ti ho chiamato ma
non volevo chiamarti realtà
madonna che strage ho fatto aiutano lo
schivato questi scriva te no meritavo di
vincere non fate domande serviva sono io
c'è una minicar vieni qui ora la madonna
scena non è successo davvero non è
successo con il rinculo sono andato giù
ma perché sole perché sono le mie armi
hanno un rinculo gli altri no c'è una
spada laser lì la voglio io l'ho battuto
di casa sono dietro fortissimo in un
momento all'altro anche questa come
storico mi sento bertino ciao verdi roba
dallo stato un fenomeno neanche mio di
matrix
ah che bello godersi gameplay bene
adesso forse non posso più [ __ ] donare
via via le reti le armi tutte a lui e
per carità va bene lui e sono
praticamente ha un senso si poteva
morire così
non lo sapevo
ma veramente basse ma sei serio ma
ragazzi bobba star che sa il gioco della
vita non è giocata roma classifica
qualcuno sta caricando
ok allora prima che non capisce
sì però miglia dai ricevitori attacco e
l'altro è questo che non ho capito
dovrebbe essere la parata in teoria ma
non pare una sega no dai lorenzo forza
kakà ti guardano 4 milioni di persone
non puoi essere un deficiente bene che è
bello che vede tiro da solo
massa o quanta violenza ci sto gioco non
avete idea è la madonna layun a chi
matrix non c'è un vero e proprio
punteggio vince chi ti ha vinto la
partita prima in poche parole io mi
metto nell'angolino da solo perché mica
go addosso a cazzola il cerchio e male
mi ha fatto ma domandano quanto è forte
il fucile a pompa non è che comprendono
fucile a pompa ho deciso dai ammazza
prima gruppo h vacca o ok mi sa che in
questo momento devo resistere contro un
giallo e può essere una cosa abbastanza
difficile
c'è un uncino aiuto porca vacca
vabbè quante armi tutela lui nicchia che
l'udc
oddio oddio calmi calmi tutti potreste
passarmi delle altre armi per favore
tipo questa non stanno di qua no che
palle dai grazia loro porca [ __ ] che
fastidio è quando da piccolo gli faccia
giallonardo il caso taci detto madre
stato uno si chiama joly è che in
italiano vuol dire luogo santo gli hai
fatto un po male visano non so perché
non è morto come come non è morto la via
ai aliena button si sfonda tutto con le
armi ovvio c'è casino perché io perché
io verso quella di sorta vacca a pinto
giallo come il blu mora e non lo capisco
sto gioco vi giuro
questo è il mio territorio vedi a ischia
tale chi è che domina è iacchetti
sono ancora pieno sole florio ho giocato
cosa senza senso ma allo stesso tempo
una delle più [ __ ] che io abbia mai
fatto negativo ma allo stesso tempo uno
dei giochi più figli che abbia mai fatto
nell'ultimo periodo e geniale comunque è
veramente una figata perché c'era una
varietà di livelli incredibili sono un
sacco di loeb e fissi ma spero vi sia
piaciuto farò sicuramente un altro
episodio anzi posso altri mille e cobas
e visione al momento che mi piace anche
vari social coniglio con descrizione
sensori fischia trini ci mettiamo un
prossimo vinto dai ragazzi
va beh
[Musica]